I took the Tactical medical course from
sheepdog we do a bunch of stress
scenarios okay you guys are hanging out
you guys are at the bank everyone's just
kind of role-playing and then some guy
was going like bang bang bang you guys
are dead you two are in charge go so
right from the start you can't just go
no you hit me
I dodged it
so now like this guy's dead wait we pick
him up we throw them in the truck it
looks pretty cool you're not supposed to
catch the bullet with my teeth
he'll end up probably just like choking
you out while he's laughed
we did a grappling scenario I had the
gun he had the knife within seconds my
gun is out of my hands and he's like
jamming me in my face and there's
nothing you can do nothing I can do
except just enjoy it
[Music]